[Music]
you has just dropped its first season on
Netflix and there is a hell of a lot to
unpack from its ending whilst I've
already broken down the show in my
previous ending explained video it's
just something that I can't get out of
my head now before I go into this theory
I just have to give a huge spoiler
warning in regards to the first season's
ending I will be discussing the events
of it so if you haven't seen it yet then
I highly suggest that you turn off now
with that out the way the thing that is
bugging me is did Beck really die in the
final episode it appears that after her
escape attempt Joe has had enough and
finally decides to kill her we are then
shown the aftermath of her death in
which your boot becomes a huge hit and
launches her into stardom but what if
she is still alive
trapped in Joe's basement living out the
rest of her days in a cage the first
thing that makes me believe this may be
the case is that we never actually see
Beck die the last we see of her is Joe's
hands around her throat but in the case
with Candice we know that even if
someone is believed to be dead it
doesn't mean that they are so who could
be in the grave that Joe dug well
personally I believe that this is Joe's
violent neighbor we all saw that he had
mob connections so it makes sense that
Joe would leave a false trail to lead
suspicion away from him Joe needed to
dispose of that body so it makes sense
that he would get rid of it in this way
in regards to Beck's therapist's arrest
sure police may have done DNA tests but
what if the confession that Beck left
was enough to implicate him Joe may have
destroyed the body enough for this and
it would be two birds with one stone
Beck was such an interesting aspect of
season 1 that it seems strange to have
her death off screen especially when the
show pulled no punches before many
people were disappointed that Beck was
killed so this could rectify their view
of the show obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on you and if you disagree
or agree with me in regards to the
character comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my original breakdown of the
show which will be linked at the end
this is a channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]